[Music]
my earliest childhood memories
was playing with legos
i loved
building lego cities with ships for the
pirates
and hospitals for the doctors
and trucks for the firefighters
it was my world of endless possibilities
and i was the architect of my own
dreams
i can also remember
that whenever i finished building a city
i would always have
one piece left over
and it was always
the same piece
it was always
the woman
only the woman
does not have a uniform
she did not have a function
she did not have a role
she was not a chef
she was not a builder she was
simply
a woman
so i didn't know what to do with her and
i'd
look around my city try to see where she
fit maybe stick her inside a house and
hope no one would notice
why was the woman
the only character that looked like me
an afterthought in my own dream
i can trace back to this memory my
decision to become an entrepreneur and a
designer because i wanted to play by my
own rules and design gave me the skills
and the tools
to build a world of my own
and as a designer i know
that the world around us is shaped by
design choices
so for that simple reason
if we have designed women out
we can design
woman in
how
the first step to jump start this change
is to realize that the world around us
is the result of what researchers call
the generic masculine
the generic masculine means that we
you
and i
we interpret everything as male unless
specified as female
it means
that when we say human
we mean man
and by making man our normal standard
human
we erase
woman from the picture
and her absences
are everywhere
there is a history right
in the policy we pursue in the cities we
plan
and the algorithms we code and in the
products we design
her absences can take the shape
of an unthreatening toy
but they can also
be deadly
women are 17
more likely to die in a car crash than
men
according to the u.s department of
transportation
why
because cars are designed for men's
bodies
car crash test dummies are designed
after men's measurements
and car seat belts are designed for
men's torsos so they simply do not
account for breast tissue or pregnancy
there are more fetal deaths from car
crashes than any other trauma and i ask
why is it this way
the leading cause of death of women in
the usa
is cardiovascular disease yet only 25
of hospital emergency treatments are
given to women
why
because diagnosis criteria were designed
to fit men's symptoms and unfortunately
a woman's heart attack looks nothing
like a man's
instead of experiencing chest and arm
pain women often experience
breathlessness
stomach pain
nausea and fatigue
her symptoms are referred to as a
typical
let that word sink in
a
typical
so instead of receiving
the treatment that she needs and
deserves
she is sent home with a prescription for
anxiety
why is it this way
and even when bias design does not kill
women it makes their life so much harder
unsafe and tiring
when we take men's perceptions patterns
and behaviors
and make them our golden rule
when we assume that what he wants does
and needs
represents us all
then our design is flawed from the
get-go
and once you see it you cannot unsee it
because it is everywhere around us
and since we stand on the stanford
campus
let's glance
at our surroundings
i see a university campus with outdoor
lighting so dim
and dispersed that female students who
live here feel unsafe at night and think
twice before choosing their paths
why didn't stanford make their walkways
brighter
because
lighting was not designed with woman in
mind
the very lengthy and very detailed
stanford lighting guidelines make it
clear light is meant to orient travelers
and to unify campus architecture
and places no emphasis on safety or
security perceptions that are central
for their female community
i can also see a full-time executive
program
that is only 25
female
why can't stanford get more executive
women to apply and come once admitted
what invisible hurdles are still there
since this program targets men and women
over 30 i'd recommend we take a long
hard look
at child care services provided
because half of the men in our program
are fathers and only three women are
mothers
how do the systems in place fail to
account for the unique challenges faced
by mothers that father surpass mothers
seven to one
why is it
this way
i believe we're in the right place and
in the right time
to redesign a world that also works for
women
because we are no longer the children
playing with the lego sets we were given
i invite you all
to reframe the way that you think of
your role from decision makers in
business in education and in policy
and to think of yourself
as designers
to everyone listening hear this
you
are a designer
because whenever you're making a
decision about what business model to
build what policy to pursue
or what strategy to roll out you are
making design choices
dear designers
know that you are powerful
use your power to advocate
for your user and their needs
all of your users
and all of their needs because they are
not in the room when you're making a
decision about them so be their voice
this responsibility
lies on all of us not just on women
and it influences all products all
services and all policies
and i ask you to go beyond the business
school questions why this
and why now
and ask the most important design
question
why is it
this way
leaders of today and leaders of tomorrow
how will you
design a world
that also works
for women
[Applause]
[Music]
you